the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so now we have this this last exercise
I'm creating a my sum I'm going to go
through all of these values and you guys
have already told me what values these
are five seven nine not eleven and I'm
going to add to my sum so I'm going to
keep a running sum adding all of these
values together okay so the very first
time through the loop my sum gets the
value of five okay that's this line here
the next thing I'm see inside this loop
is an if statement if my sum is equal to
five that's true so I'm going to go
inside this if statement the next thing
I see is a break if I see this break and
my evaluating am i evaluating this line
or not
no exactly because whenever Python sees
break it's going to say I'm going to
stop right here exit out of the loop
that I'm currently in and go to the
statement that's immediately right after
it so what this is going to print is my
son and that's the exercise we were
looking at let's see how the class did
pretty good hopefully if you answered
one of these the explanation was was all
right if not just go back and try to
work through it step-by-step